You know I have waited where you haven't sat right or first outside that guy.
It's time to start I mean when you were growing up your kid you know had it
when we did you first feel you were more fully in Marnie the witch with your child or your i was trying to stay
or yeah it was very curious about chickens and all remember after the family about it
when told by Mr Freeman everything that you say officers knew was a family next door that pretty girl
or boy was there for those twelve and yellow one whether anyone or saw them on Diane there from reading.
Playing around to say you know I watched you I was finished up for knowledge for the dawn upon light of the things
when you night on the hour.
Why the doors
and sit in the last night here because what pressure night in the fact that he had like three pointers just so you know
so you know what they're here and any ride I finished up. He finished and I knew the court system.
Then or I was watching the I was more rigorous you know go in there and you know yes i wanted me to do the same thing.
The younger girls say like an impossible thing from very high and I had meter on when mom
and seventy explanation right there. All I was writing so I shut the bedroom which is very unusual for the family.
They're very strict all that there are and I've seen that right. They all.
And I went down and I told we have a recent poll that said marriage
and I should also understand it says that there might mean doubt very careful or you had something to do with sex
but there are many right.
It was known through his life that some of the kids had gone there to play in the fall
when they are not there for them while the price for that took me in something under six.
You know the big four or for the stuff there and you know it just was just to the on you or I didn't really
and it wasn't terribly in the fashion
or in life before it got the thing was really going very well for a couple that was frowned upon such a notion to do.
It sort of got me that it was all that there can be found. There. And where you had pictures of you there. Oh yeah.
That was jumping. He was right here right.
In that we got together again a little cubicle a bit just to take a look at the that's the first. No I didn't hear but.
It was something you know what they're picked up for kept coming one more one up to hear your opinion on the piles of
money something you say to the Lord.
It was down in the final of the great joy ride when they picked me up
and we finished up north of it just down into the fire marker because or it was a very face is red and it brought.
If it's all right that in the lore of it live with my brother. He did not want to do it down my street.
If you don't want one for you to condone this again if you are then young black next door here in the back yard used to
get arrested by their owners. Yes I know that they're gone now.
They all be devoutly scared or if they are seem like they're on the top there was a Sunday. That's right.
Anyway I always say one longs something and you are not sitting up on the floor or on the floor dive the fun
when the just one on the ground on life. There is a fortune life and laughter that just leave it there guys.
Horses get sort of the depression for years. You see I am there for you.
I want to live there for a while an operation right. I've had a doctor get a doctor.
Actually there and why we're here and why each one of me to get a little bit on this
or no I think you are starting to get to the offender.
Here here and when there are some very good if you ask you to come here or any lie.
I have with my future wife of forty anywhere and there you are with and all thought might be.
They are yeah when or if that progression. This year I forgot what I hear hear about the X.
Ray and a very fun ride and I had a talk here
and there a lot of the vice like the rock group to do that sort of with your high. The girls. I am here anyway.
And I mourn with the days of my letter that you did stay as a child of course horses just short of a voice that you
hear that all are the force for the war that's why I didn't really know I was it was very I always have to have done it
and you don't like it
when I was a bear that I that was one of the good always doing the early on then they had the stuff to get a place of
but that was very clear how it will come off into some us all things would be fine and I was really bad.
Then something like that for a for like every month
or more if this were the thirty's one that is if the very thought of them all
and why it sounds we used to get together. I never worked like a real choice but then I wish to practice on a voyage.
All right now see if you get right on the boat. That was just my own members.
I thought this was another sort of one where it gets in there or it can go you know you
and I sort of nine of them alive and we've got a camera here
and it was sort of a little rough building their efforts to find a five gallon. One of them.
With sex with a few of you. One time just how they normally do business here but no one was there.
Everyone could just sort of coming coming here. You know that was for good was very cost very much.
One and it was me and the other sort of summary.
Right but never quite a side room it was the fountain out of all that sort of stuff that not going to war
or a real bomb myself but know that you still get the there was a bit in the thirty's story a good toilet
and just me and one or yeah there the yeah there in the west of the cliffs.
Yeah and it still is or they gave us a look on the level house.
Three weeks ago and it was still pretty guys hanging around outside so it's still going on there
and it's various parties will crash the bows down and I've got a clip of the clip there but they're just a long way
when you went out. They listened five. That's right. You said Right but. The way they get here.
There was a fight for the one year that was actually very they were in the city.
I mean they say that you know Frank straight down to the cathedral.
They say that used to be true it is a really nice day in the city.
If our minds what's wrong with the toilets of rock you want to die and if you say it
and you realize it's coming up this way and I just saw it here here
and there was one of them in their room right there that's going down down towards the bottom bizarre because the place
you wonder what you're looking at here.
Yes because the Archibald failed was that there was that was also our supposedly a bit in those times too.
It wasn't yet every person you know if you get one here you see someone you know dear.
And then your boss of the time you hear your soul starting something else that you want with which but here
and then of course there was the Washburn which was it. Actually yeah yeah actually with the ashes here.
Here they are she can't think how to help. Yet you can hear that they are there. The dog that's right.
Yeah this is in the thirty's it's called the dog or when. With the rebuilder That's right.
I can remember when it was rebuilt think of the dugout that was the fifty's or sixty's.
Yet here they're living off of here. That's one thing file it was another one.
I mean it's a big guy and I told you that you could go in there with that but after that. Every one of the guys there.
I said if they're capable of what he was doing here.
Then of course there was a way that if they stuck it or it wasn't really one of the voices here
or the family farm which my are right that none of you were the one of your family that I would go for it because I
would not. I just want to hear what it was now it is so much though.
Certain that we thought that really hard was a comforting thing was a four year lighter on the rescue six.
Generally this is something that when it goes on and you know one of the dead felt that he had to do it whatever.
Was once the when it was you know deficit and there's fire.
Then you go there anyway they're not pushing thirty no on I was just there or I do recall off
or another of those the mine very own players.
That's the effect if it's at the fact they're not there yet here you know they're our down to you know it.
The essential did why they're here where you're wrong sore the news on the technology you know what I did.
There was three take then yeah that's right.
Yeah they should do and I am recovered told some of the building I really thought that a little
but I can get by with a I think the said a lot of action. A lot of there was a lot of tried just people coming in here.
I said that all of the talk show you how all bets are off and think that they're not yet here I sit here
and I'm just like a few not a whole lot of take.
Could get into doing that and everything checked in on some of them for me to ever get why sometimes avoid it
but I'll get you in the mood for sitting down for the rest but not.
The fact that or yeah right or yeah it was very hard for us to do
or Sapphire it comes down to a lot of things then a guy might do that or you know go forward.
Sarka give a few players there. Then you know if your room. Struck. Yeah yeah me sure that was the message.
So it sort of got it here when I sat there with the it will annoy me
or three you are going to start a war with itself alone.
They sure are not going to have a real areas of darkness or it might be
or have to have a white ghost of any stuff that has a disclaimer that Tommy of air force fit the bill for the good he
with my habit of let them think it was guy that they brought in on there with a bouncy chair for Scotty
and his wife some stuff here we have here done a few times. If there were that much.
I'm a fan of yours of the prime of this whole life stuff always know you're used to doing that
and that's where they end up because by the way very affectionate boys to think of it is very affectionate for much
more than what yet whether it was a guy with you or whether he did not hear them say I am more than me
and you're the sign and I went through the front door of Britney's World War two What's on there yet never right now.
And I'm going to show up for another very five of you in a switch.
It will not have the final the traditional way so that is a very very long way staff there was a while.
And you never quite get the one that was there and all that they all sort of action here and kind of back.
I reckon on the line by the way back in the right way for a rhyme.
That's the thing and I found I had a little bit of the floor as if it was simony but not
when I was up there thirty seven months.
You know if the animal waited for what it was I get to die or so when one of them said
or for the art of war by the way.
Maggie and your young while if you get lost in one of the say the wire for the fall of one fall
or was in a new war that was the fifth in the way to the front office the top of the or the hallway
or there in that whatever. You mean I was out of the door the form of noise that will hit that yet.
Anyway employees or the rest of the Irish. And it was only they were told over this picture of it.
I never had that with you and I was on one of those
and there it was in a khaki sized one that were in the distance here with us.
And I got into you know one of these to where they actually have this thing as a minister that what you do
and I think what you did was just a storm that a lot of the idea.
Did was for them and I read what I was more a nationalist that it was throwing their family here
and it's now a wave of war and then I get watching the stuff like that which they still read it is
when I read about the guy that won it and it and my wife will I live for them if it was just a one way
or some other war. So was it looks six with the wire and where were the five one gallon that picture.
One of the first one comes with it or a fun place there and there was a banner that. Still there.
What what did you want the end of that it was so somebody's got to get it to the home and get you there.
Again just as much more try to stuff it.
And you decide to for so long as you could say that there was never a choice or I don't want that
and I'm going to sign it if I thought that that anyone that they got such a structure to show off a little you actually
did that and did you say you are the guys in the unit or around the idea were a guy for the left of the law he was
but he never made it never even went so if the city had a few more you know very anxious of their the fact that if they
get a lot of money in the way they offset the ordering debate.
By that I thank you for the betterment of the office and the Off we go.
It's a competition they I when I was one of the teams in the second year they try
and fight crime in the areas that I like and they're biased and sort of thought we were there and we had a thirty
or forty somewhere that wherever you went shout.
Some silly thing some of the pictures of around here then that for very very poor
or if the you hear that I got six in we'll get over six.
I would be guys down on the fact that it was generally accepted that the office that he's a child of your voice that
guides me I want to use a way to get a lot of money. It was a guy's I'm just just done. Not to want to watch the show.
He was shot seven forty one is so right. How do you do. I am not qualified to Roy.
That was after the end of the darkroom. The big room and it was curious. They were there and you know went on.
When we were on our human rights friends for a year ahead of the coaster going as I was we went to a very easy day.
Of yet
or are you know this is to last question just before I go given everything about the Turkish policy in the book Liverpool
Street now given the job. Files of the before the election.
The winning four year old was before the boy did not hear what was the other two things something we were interested in
about. And he had money.
Rather the more you know stuff to just get more money and it was for that including much money in coins of ninety nine.
Nationally Let's run it for the money before someone putting dollars here. And yes he made his money.
That's why you buy any more but if you are going to go out. Well yeah.
And anyway I showered for a couple bucks on sending them to what you hear the white
or the little if any of your you want to solve that day I mean that by a different voice here said I don't hear much of.
Was there any I see today. I've got through then it must get on a.
Then there was a very well known to the sun sign right there.
Yeah just to put that one right guy
when he wasn't that much against a lot of you ARE YOU WATCHING THE LOVE YOU say I that I can buy a style
or still just five seconds left in the right guy for the oil right guy.
So that's why I always try to write them all up on the fact that all this guy
and you are right the way they did not this. I didn't or you are forced to yell at us here which read just done.
And if not if this is the word good God would just say nice. So if you were lucky it was a. A long time back.
What is left that they what goes back here a lot of rich from the one with here with the with a guy that dies want to
marry. It was natural get to the heart of the system.
My brother and so I just want to know what to ask three four to five there
and then sort of the other side of the family are one of them did you want the sort of my initial one airing that I was
invited to if Iran did what you did that it was OK it was would've done what a sort of white shark that what we had was
what the game was really annoyed sort of the way they are more than almost anything that was nothing out there.
What sort of stuff you know what was the who was a very driven minute it's that interest as to what sort of information
people could get their own house from.
They are one minor part of the three story or four or more border everything the North lost
and therefore the difference here is that it might if you're a little bit of was that all of this
or a bit of for a bit of me going to reach the feature for the nation the information here
or on the over the movement report a year
or so I gather that the various actually ships a lot of the run the guy that the previous done a lot of which surprised
by a sex object that the lawyer for it was written for the story of their car buyer.
Somebody which is an excuse to give that there's one why destroy a lot of it is that in a civil war a city that had to
look stuff
and see every well watch I use that so very little if you can put your hand if you can get get them I'm a sucker for
tonight.
Then why can't I get a good one there was nothing in the way that one of the first boy I didn't join into any guy where
they were annoyed at him. OK but that was the more I think this is the part that a lot of trees.
You know where they were mean you know if you know the reason why we like a lot of the way some of.
You know you would mine a city my city is not like you. I'm here. It was because I said here.
You guys son is scale based and I can't ever drive so that was here that was also I'm just worried.
We will get more oil for oil.
When I come back I want to the center store
and get all the boys went for a walk now over here toward a world where so are all of us while he was educated.
You know not it's got your common sense get your life even if you are either with that Mary box were in one form
or there was more that there is not good for you possibly with these places with people with the scalpels with I have
to ring the scales What are they saying they want to write a for just a social club Oh yeah it's just a meeting here.
It was and I called so I'm so I really thought it was kind of good to hear you
but I have no wife there I didn't go I didn't really do because of my Do they were few
and force the camps that clubs really. When I was just down there wasn't a whole I travel across in the sixty's.
One of those little streets running down from a client straight or a straight if there been a place where the old one.
They say the jury. There was a lot of a right shoulder with a straight.
This week this modifies obviously you can get your X. Ray or it will be a full size.
That's when you hear something you hear like that. I want you. So when you hear.
We heard that they were during the war and even there it's your wife your wife. Right. The wife. You.
OK And you can see here. She's the kids go to the world that is which will go.
So hard for us to get back there was really much of what they do if she wanted to do it.
So we just died for always showing up.
Out there with the SAT for them showing the verses of what actually insist on one gets fed up with corruption
but the rest of the license rules for the not to get silence in the what is it an orphan boy.
She was heartless or eventually Arianne disordered story line sort of day at work or saw something
and then went back to the food or sat there. So you see something with so much.
I was sort of a guy a little money in that I could never know what they're getting at in interest on such dogs
but money from my Yeah so if you're under somebody's France. Going to the bank and money money in the bank.
What's all of that one for three Going to the next
and so joining you on the check was the only time she ever used here was like that. When. Well.
Let's go let's go let's check the she asked one white guy. Give me a check.
I'd give you a check or that much of for you know just or get back here
and she said you know what you can never not just sign the fear that she is like trying to push what you want to make a
list of all Wasn't there a way to ask a bit more but all I want to get business here.
If you give me the money when I get here. I can't possibly the site there I didn't want to upset. Any.
Sorry once or let this dog wife my kids are here on tech. So there is a special time right here.
Not that I did never a few or think the wife says yes or flight guy. They're here to get a message there.
The money money. Yeah yeah the trucker the article. That he's here writing why.
It gets sixty dollars and it has a profession which is very laid back. Right now because. The fifty's sixty's.
Because I couldn't do it because there's.